and I'm here today to show you how you
can write a data visualization app for
your phone using nothing but python uh
before I start I'd like to acknowledge
that I'm speaking to you today from
wajuka buja otherwise known as Perth
Western Australia uh and I'd like to
recognize the wajuka as the traditional
loaners traditional owners of this land
to recognize their continuing connection
to these lands Waters and culture and to
pay my respects to their Elders past
present and
emerging a little bit about me uh I am a
principal engineer in the open source
grou group at anaconda anaconda supports
the python open source ecosystem by
providing direct financial support to
organizations like num Focus uh and by
employing developers to work full-time
on open source projects projects like
Jupiter and number and the open source
project that I founded bware for those
that haven't come across it before
beware is not a single product or
library or tool it is a collection of
Open Source tools and libraries for
creating native user interfaces in
Python for desktop but also for iOS for
Android the single page web apps and
console apps each tool in the suite
solves one very specific part of the
overall problem of writing a guey app in
Python and distributing that app to
other people on various platforms
andaconda supports beware to ensure that
python remains a viable programming
language on the platforms that people
are increasingly using as part of their
day-to-day Computing life phones tablets
and so on however it is important to
note that bware is not an anaconda
product or anything like that it is a
fully open-source project with
independent governance and funding I
just happen to be paid by anacona to
work on it full-time and so today we're
going to look at the bware suite of
tools and how you can use those tools to
deploy the python data science and
visualization libraries that you're
probably already familiar with to deploy
a an iOS and an Android app from a
single python codebase this is going to
involve two major pieces of the beware
Suite the first is toga toga is beare's
crossplatform gooey toolkit it lets you
use a single codebase to write a goey
application that can Target multiple
platforms and on each of those platforms
you get a native user interface so on
Macos it will look like a Macos app on
iOS it will look like an IOS app and so
on it isn't just a cosmetic appearance
either the apps are native toga
abstracts the native system widgets and
capabilities providing a common pythonic
API to build apps this also means you
inherit all the native capabilities of
those platforms so for example
accessibility affordances like screen
readers and adapt font sizes just
work the second piece of bware we're
going to use is briefcase briefcase is a
tool for packaging python applications
it takes your python code wraps it up as
a standalone unit that can be given to
an end user with no python experience at
all so they can install it on their
device of choice without ever knowing
that they're running python code in our
case we're going to use briefcase to
prepare an IOS and Android app that
could be submitted to those platforms
respective app stores now while it
obviously pairs very well with toga
briefcase is not beware or toga specific
you can use briefcase to deploy a py
game app if you wanted to briefcase
can't magically make py game work on
Android but to the extent that a gooey
Library supports a platform toga can
support deploying it to that
platform all right so let's Dive Right
In let's run an app and then deploy it
to IOS and Android for demo purposes I'm
going to keep it reasonably simple but
not completely trivial we want to be a
to use the python data science libraries
we're familiar with so let's use numpy
to generate a random series of data and
then use matplot lib to build a
histogram of that data series one of the
benefits of using an app is that you
want users to be able to interact with
the data so let's make sure that's
possible we'll use a couple of Sliders
to control the mean and standard
deviation of the random data and we'll
provide a button to just generate
completely new random data with the same
mean and standard deviation and we want
to show this is crossplatform so we'll
deploy it to both IOS and Android from
the same source code base with no
modification
so where do we start well briefcase has
a wizard you can use to bootstrap a new
app so create a new virtual environment
and install briefcase pip install
briefcase with briefcase installed you
can then run the wizard to start a new
project you run briefcase new and you'll
be presented with a list of questions
with explanatory text you'll be prompted
for a formal name it's the name of the
app you show to humans uh and an app
name a python version of the name
something you would pip install so so
let's use Pata demo for this new appb
you'll be asked for a bundle this is
used for namespacing to separate my
Piata demo from your Piata demo this is
a common format that's used by app
stores it's usually a reversed ordering
of a domain name that you you control so
in my case or. beware that bundle is
then combined with the app name to make
a full bundle ID for your app or.
beware. pyata
demo you'll be asked for a project name
a briefcase project can include multiple
distributed apps in this case we'll just
default to the app's formal name we'll
be asked for a oneline description of
your project for an author's name and
email that's used in help text and
copyright uh labels uh you be asked for
a URL for the project a license and
lastly a gooey framework we're going to
use togga for this example but there are
also templates for pide pursued pip air
py game or you can select an empty
project with no goey toolkit at
all when you complete the wizard
briefcase can generate that app and it
will give you instructions on how to run
the project so let's follow those
instructions we CD P data demo and run
briefcase down
briefcase includes a developer mode
which lets you rapidly iterate on your
app and its configuration when you run
briefcase Dev briefcase looks at the
projects configuration works out how to
run the project in your local virtual
environment the first time you do this
it'll install some dependencies based
upon what your template generated uh and
then it will start your app for what
it's worth briefcase Dev is really not a
not lot not not that much more than a
convenient shorthand for pip install
followed by python minus M Pi data demo
with a couple of debug Flags turned on
and some environment stuff set
up and if all you've got is the content
generated by your wizard at this point
what you'll see is a working app it will
be an empty window but it will be a
fully working native app in this case on
Macos let's take a closer look at what
was generated for us by the wizard if
you look into the Pata demo folder
that's been generated you'll find the
code for the App application icons in
variety formats and project metadata
you'll get the same files regardless of
which guey tool guey framework you pick
the only difference will be the contents
of app.py dund main.py and some of the
values in P project atom and readme and
the license file let's take a look at
those files and and see what's see
what's in there py project. toml is the
configuration file for your project
contents of this file will match the
answers that you gave in the Wizard all
the tool case all the briefcase options
are defined in a tool. briefcase section
and subsections of this configuration
file the top level project and author
identification is all in just a straight
tool.
briefcase individual app s are then
defined in their own sections so this
configuration section defines a pi data
demo app that's the app name with a
formal name of Pi dat demo and so on at
runtime the configuration for the pi dat
demo app is composed from the project
settings overridden by the app settings
so even though there isn't an author
name defined here in this app config it
will inherit one from the project level
definition on the previous slide if you
wanted to have a different author name
for for this app in your project you
could do so by including an author name
in the apps configuration block now I
said that the app settings override
project settings there are four
exceptions to this override Behavior
sources requires test sources and test
requires sources defines the list of
directories of source code that you want
to include in your app here we're saying
Source Piata demo directory uh any code
or resources in that folder will be
copied into your app it's a list so if
you specify multiple sources they'll all
be copied the only requirement is that
one of your Source directories needs to
match the name of your app so P dat demo
in this case requires defines the python
requirements for your app again as a
list using the same format you'd use as
an argument to pip install so a bare
package name a package with a version
specifier a git repository or a path to
a local folder that contains an
installable package they're all valid
options here test sources and test
requires are the same as sources and
requires but they Define code that will
only be included when you're running
running the app in test mode these four
settings are cumulative settings so if
you specify a sources definition at the
project level any app level sources will
be appended to the list defined at the
project level why does this matter well
you can also specify options that are
platform specific by adding a
configuration section for that platform
the generated p project. toml uh will
include a section for all the supported
platforms Macos Linux Windows iOS
Android and web so here we've got
specification for IOS and Android of our
Piata demo app these options will only
apply to the building the builds of the
app on those platforms sources requires
test sources and test requires are
cumulative so any deployment on iOS will
install the app level requirements from
the previous slide but also will install
toga iOS and SS standard NS log a
deployment on Android will have the same
app level requirements but won't have
toger iOS or standard log uh standard NS
log they'll have to Android instead all
the other settings will override app
level and project level value so you
could have an iOS specific author name
for example that's the project
configuration what about the app itself
well the logic for the app is all
contained in app.py at the moment it's
bed up it declares a class called Piata
demo which is a subclass of to.app and
that class has a startup method that
method creates a box that's toa's
representation of a generic container of
content uh it creates a main window and
sets the content of the main window to
be our empty box and then it shows that
main window the main men main method for
the app just creates an instance of that
class and uh the app the briefcase
process will start that uh start that
main method that's all the code we need
to generate the empty app that we saw
previously so let's bulk this out a
little bit now with a real app let's
replace the content of our startup
method uh we start with a main window
same as before now we want to draw a
chart we're going to use toga chart
which is a matplot lib backend that can
render natively to toga so we create an
instance of this instance of a chart
widget from toga chart two details in
the instant in the Constructor for this
uh uh chart widget toga lets you set the
style of each widget using a subset of
CSS called pack so we tell toga here
that we want the widget to be flexible
we want it to expand into any available
space and we set an on draw Handler now
whenever the chart needs to draw itself
it will invoke a method on the app
called Draw chart uh this is an event
handler it can be a bare function a
method on a class or an synchronous Co
routine and we'll Define this method a
little bit later
on continuing our startup method uh we
also want some sliders to control our
random data so let's create a slider
called me to create control the mean of
our generated data it's going to have an
initial value of 100 but it can range
from0 to 200 uh it also has an event
handler on change so whenever the value
of the slider changes we want to invoke
recreate data again we'll come back to
that one in a bit when we put the slider
on the St on the screen we're going to
want to have a label next to it and we
want the label to be beside the widget
so let's create a box whose children are
a label with a me and the MU widget that
we just created by default boxes are
laid out horizontally the same way as
they are in
HTML and we'll also modify the style
saying that we want the slider to expand
size if it can We'll add some padding
around the widgets in this box five
pixels top and bottom 10 on the left and
right that's the same syntax that used
for CSS
padding now that's the M slider we also
want to change the standard deviation so
let's set up a second slider called
Sigma that's almost the same as the MU
slider except that instead of um initial
value of 100 and a min max of 0 and 200
we're going to have an initial value of
15 and a range from 1 to 30 also notice
here that the slider widget has been
assigned to self. Sigma so it's a
property of the app that we're building
but the box is just a bare Sigma box and
the label isn't assigned to anything at
all that's because we're going to need
to access the value of the slider
throughout the app whereas the Box only
needs to be refer to later in the
startup process as part of sort of the
construction of building things and the
label doesn't need to be referred to at
all it just needs to be put in the
Box we also want to be able to
regenerate data so we'll create a button
we need to set the text of the button so
we'll have a recreate button recre
recreate data label on the button and
when the button is pressed we need to
handle that event so we'll have an
onpress event handler uh that invokes
the same recreate data event handler
we've used for the two sliders after all
it doesn't matter if we change the mean
standard deviation or just want new data
we're going to need to redraw the chart
we'll also give the button some padding
as
well now we can start to put all the
pieces together before we draw the chart
for the first time we're going to need
to have some initial data for the uh for
the chart being drawn so we'll wrap that
up in a set data method we'll come back
to that in a minute as well uh we can
set the content of our main window our
main window will consist of a box that
contains a chart the box with a mean
slider and label the box with the
standard deviation slider and label and
the regenerate button Now by default
boxes lay content out horizontally but
we want these four widgets to be laid
out vertically so we'll set the style of
the main content box so that it's a
column box and that's our startup method
so now we can fill in some of the gaps
that I referred to along the way uh we
need to set I need to have a set data
method to define a data series that's
easy enough um we use nump to generate a
series of a thousand random numbers on a
normal distribution multiply the value
by the sigma slider to give a
distribution some spread and then add
the value of the M slider to set the
mean we then store the result as the X
attribute of the app so we can access it
anywhere we need to all right we also
need an event handler for when the data
is recreated whenever whenever either of
the slightest change or the button is
pressed um we need to regenerate the
data so we call set data and then we
tell the chart to redraw itself just a
manual hey go redraw uh the as recreate
data is an event handler the first
argument to that Handler is the widget
that generated the event in our case we
don't actually care which widget
generated the event but if we did care
the detail is there for us to
use lastly we need to actually draw the
chart uh this is also an event handler
when the redraw is triggered either
because the window is resized or because
redraw has been directly requested this
is the Handler that gets invoked as it's
an event handler the first argument is
the widget that generated the event the
chart but it also gets a figure argument
which is a literal matplot lib figure
instance and so we can draw on that
figure using any matplot lib API you
wanted so let's add a subplot generate a
histogram with buckets in the same range
as that M slider 0 to 200 label our axes
and set the figure to have a type layout
and that's it we've got a demo app that
draws a
chart okay but before we deploy to our
phone let's just use development mode to
actually just check that everything's
working so we can run briefcase Dev and
oh it's got to crash because it can't
find numpy well that's embarrassing
we're using numpy in our project but we
haven't installed numpy so let's modify
our project to declare our dependenc
let's go back to our P project. toml the
app section declares our requirements so
we need both a numpy and tokka chart as
dependencies toek chart specifies a a
dependency on matplot lib so that'll be
installed trans transitively as well so
save those changes uh now run briefcase
Dev minus r the extra minus r is needed
because our requirements have changed so
that will go through and say okay let's
have a look at the requirements and
install them all we'll install numpy
tooch chart all the requirements of
those packages and and then you see an
app with a chart two sliders and a
button if you press the button you get a
fresh sample of a thousand data points
if you move the sliders you'll the chart
will update itself to modify the mean
and the standard
deviation Okay so we've got a WRA
running in development mode Let's get it
on our phone first step we need to
create our app let's target iOS first so
we invoke briefcase create iOS this will
do a bunch of things first it will check
that you have xcode installed and if you
don't it'll direct you to the App Store
and give you a download link if it is
installed briefcase will get an
application template for the platform
this is a code template providing all
the scaffolding and project files needed
to support a python app on iOS then you
will obtain a support package support
package is a pre-compiled version of
python that can be embedded into your
app briefcase downloads the support
package unpacks it into the application
template that was just
unrolled then briefcase installs your
application code anything declared in
the sources section of your project it
then downloads and installs all of your
apps requirements it doesn't install
them into your local virtual environment
though and doesn't use anything in your
local virtual environment it installs
them into the application template as a
standalone environment we are building
an app for distribution so we can't rely
on anything that is on my local machine
my local virtual environment also we
need binaries that will work on iOS so
our local installed versions of numpy
and matplot liip wouldn't work on a
phone
anyway then briefcase installs any
application resources like icons it
purges any content that isn't needed and
it's done you've now got a complete
application template for iOS that essent
essentially means a full xcode project
you don't need to touch anything in that
project though it's there in the build a
build folder but you don't need to don't
need to do anything to it the next step
is to build the app to do that briefcase
build iOS this will literally compile
the xcode project that was just
generated again you don't have to open
the xcode project write any Objective C
code or Swift Code you just need to run
briefcase build iOS and that will
compile it now this can be a little
noisy on the console if you run this
today you will get a bunch of warnings
about capability item models not being
defined uh These Warnings can be ignored
it's actually a bug in xcode briefcase
is constantly playing whacka mole hiding
xcode warnings that you can safely
ignore uh the build will take maybe a
minute it takes a it needs to process
all the binary modules in the standard
Library all the binary modules on your
dependencies sign them package the app
into a bundle that can be sent to a
phone and once it's compiled you can run
it briefcase run iOS run the app on the
iOS simulator on your laptop uh if you
do just a straight briefcase run iOS
you'll be asked what simulator will you
want to run on do you want an iPhone SE
or an iPhone 15 Pro Max or an iPad your
pick when you do make your selection
briefcase will tell you the syntax to
shortcut that question next time and
specify the device directly from the
command
line uh you can't deploy to an iOS
device directly from the command line
yet but you can using another command
that I'll mention in a moment and what
you'll see is a running app functionally
it'll be ident IAL to what you saw from
briefcase Dev but with a couple of
distinct differences obviously it's
phone shaped but also the widgets are
now iOS specific widgets the slider and
the button are iOS style buttons and
Sliders and if you turn your phone on
its side it will respond to the aspect
change the widgets that were marked as
flexible will resize in the axes you ask
them to be
flexible Okay so we've successfully run
our app on the iOS simulator can you run
on Android as well well yes you just go
through the same process replacing iOS
with Android there's three very slight
differences though firstly if Android
Studio isn't installed briefcase can
manage the download process for you
takes about 10 minutes to on my machine
anyway to download the whole of Android
Studio but it will just manage it you
don't have to go through the through
through an app store secondly Android
Studio doesn't ship with any default
devices so you'll be prompted to create
an emulator device uh but briefcase will
walk you through that wizard through a
wizard to manage that process once
you've created an emulator once you can
use the same emulator for any Android
project down the line and third uh as on
iOS you can if you just say run Android
when you get to the Run step you'll be
prompted to choose a device to run on
however Android will let you deploy
directly to a physical device if you
plug your phone in by USB cable it will
appear as a Target where with briefcase
can deploy you do need to do a little
bit of configuration to make this work
you need to turn on USB debugging on
your device and then there's a weird
dance you need to do to enable to to
developer mode but again briefcase we'll
walk you through we'll do what it can to
walk you through that process and again
you get a running app this time in the
Android
emulator okay so with created built and
run our app on both IOS and Android uh
then you want to make a change do we
need to go through this whole create
build run process again well you can uh
or you can just use briefcase update by
default this will reinstall the code for
the app if you want to update
requirements as well say we updated a
dependency on pandas uh you can or we
added a dependency on pandas you can
specify minus r if you want to update
application resources like icons you can
specify D- update
resources some other the features that
are worthy of of note uh we have been
demonstrating IOS and Android here um
but briefcase can also be used to deploy
to Macos windows and Linux desktops uh
the apps that are generated are
completely Standalone what you get out
of the build process is an MSI installer
or a Macos DMG or a Linux Deb or RPM
package uh you can take that bundle and
give it to anyone and the app will just
start you don't need to teach them how
to install python how to create a
virtual environment or so on you just
give them a download link they download
the app they double click on it and the
app starts if you don't specify a
platform briefcase will default to
building an app for your current
platform so I'm on a Mac laptop a bare
briefcase create will create a Macos app
uh some platforms also have multiple
output formats so you can produce a flat
pack uh on Linux for
example briefcase will also imply
earlier steps if they're needed if you
have a fresh project straight out of
briefcase new and you go straight to
briefcase run briefcase will detect
there isn't a template yet and create it
and then build it and then run it uh
briefcase run also allows for a-u option
so that which will will update the app
before execution so you know your
development process could be just
briefcase run minus you over and over
and over again uh briefcase open is
another command that's handy it will
open your project on Android that's just
a file manager on the folder that
contains your Android gradal project but
on iOS it will open your app in xcode
when you are ready to run your app on a
physical device or to submit your app to
the App Store that's what you'll have to
do um I haven't got time to go through
that process today but the briefcase
documentation does walk you through
it the demo app here we've used is using
numpy and matplot lib what about other
third party packages well it depends um
if the package you want to use and its
dependencies are pure python you can
just use it put it on your requires list
briefcase updates minus r you're done
the only place it falls down is if that
package has if cy. platform equals
something logic in it in which case you
might need to patch it to add iOS or
Android support anything with binary
modules that's a little bit more
complicated on desktop binary wheels
just work they installed distributed
without any difficulty on mobile binary
wheels just work too but most projects
don't publish binary wheels for IOS and
Android if only because they can't be
uploaded to Pipi in fact bware is the
only group currently building binary
wheels for IOS and Android uh we
maintain an independent pip compatible
repository that where they're stored and
briefcase uses those repositories if the
package you want isn't on that the list
that briefcase provides or is on the
list that briefcase provides you're fine
if it isn't building can be complicated
depending upon the package we've got
many of the more more common packages
numpy pandas pillows some older versions
of cryptography but we're a small team
and rebuilding the universe takes some
time um we have documented the process
of adding a build recipe but some
packages are just harder than others
unfortunately scipi and open CV are two
commonly requested packages that aren't
available on iOS at the moment because
they need a Fortran compiler and there
isn't a Fortran compiler for iOS this is
something that we are looking working on
and looking at speaking of future work
what's coming in the future well
permissions are a big item on our to-do
list the most significant these are most
significant on mobile where you need to
ask for specific permissions to access
the camera or access to GE location
services these permissions are becoming
increasingly uh common on desktop as
well speaking of integration with device
sensors right now briefcase beware
doesn't have any crossplatform apis for
accessing device sensors like cameras
and accelerometers you can use those
sensors you just need to call the native
platform apis so native Android native
iOS apis over the language bridges that
bware provides using the same language
bridges that toga uses to access the
native widgets it's entirely possible
does require a little bit of expertise
and sort of reading some strange
documentation as strange in terms of
alien platform
documentation uh We've also begun the
process of getting iOS to official tier
three support in Python pep 30 pip 7:30
was accepted earlier this week by the
steering Council uh the first patches
have already landed to add that iOS
support see the pet for details uh we're
hoping to start the same process for
Android in the very near future this
should unlock allowing binary modules
for mobile to be uploaded onto
pii and that's beware if you do nothing
else I recommend going through the bware
tutorial docs. b.org uh bware has a
briefcase has plenty of configuration
options and other details I haven't gone
into though if you do want to know more
briefcases documentation is fairly
thorough um I've also only just touched
on the very surface of toga toa's
documentation contains a lot more
details and the toga GitHub repository
has a lot of example code and the code
for today's demo is largely the same as
the example project in the toga chart
repos repository if you like what you've
seen here you'd like to support this
work on briefcase and the beware project
uh you can join the project as a
financial member you can also back me on
GitHub sponsors um or if working kind is
more your thing we've also always
looking for new contributors we have a
long list of features we like to add we
have challenge coins for people who
contribute um we'd love to love to see
people come up and and help thank you
all very much
thank you I can see a question uh on the
what chat uh uh which is about
blly
um is that something that
is uh I'm trying to see the the question
here um yes so what about ble do do you
have have you tried mobile app with
plotly uh I have not tried plotly lit uh
um directly
um good question I don't know is the
short answer uh the way to find out is
is does plotly have a pi3 any none wheel
or is it a binary wheel if it's a binary
wheel something will need to be compiled
um if it's if it's just a a pure python
wheel then you likely can just straight
up use it